GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH A TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
. LIKE TO START THE IN THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU WE HAD WE
WILL HAVE A HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
BILLS TO CONSIDER THIS MORNING
AS A PART OF OUR REGULAR
ORDERED. HEARING A BEFORE WE
BEGAN I HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
NOTES TO COVER FIRST I'D LIKE
TO- ACKNOWLEDGE AND WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORI WILSON. WHO
IS NEW TO OUR COMMITTEE WE
WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. ARE WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO AS I CAN MOVE FORWARD
AND GIVE YOU CENTER HOUSEKEEPING
AROUND THE ORDER OF THIS
MEETING. URGING PUBLIC IN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING THE- COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AT. A PRO SIMPLY DOT CA DOT GOV
BACKSLASH PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT AND MAY BE READ
INTO THE RECORD WERE REPRINTED
ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE
HEARING FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AT W. W. W. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA AGO BACKSLASH
TO. EVENTS THE HEARING ROOM WILL
BE OPEN FOR ATTENDANCE FOR OF
THIS HEARING. THE PUBLIC MAY
ALSO PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING
BY PHONE BY CALLING EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN WITH CONFIRMATION
CODE ONE EIGHT FIVE. ZERO ONE
ONE ZERO ZERO THAT NUMBER IS
ALSO LISTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC
TO MONITOR. WEBSITE FOR UPDATES
. WE WILL ACCEPT PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ANY BILL PLACED ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE BY THE COMMITTEE
TODAY NEVER WHICH THE AUTHOR WAY
PRESENTATION. BEFORE THE CLOSE
OF THE REGULAR ORDER HEARING
TESTIMONY ON THESE BILLS WILL BE
LIMITED TO A STATEMENT OF NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. THE COMMITTEE WILL ALLOW
NO MORE THAN FORTY MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY ON A GIVEN BILL.
PREFERENCE WILL BE GIVEN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. DO THE CODE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE LIMITED SPACE
FOR. FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE. SO WE CAN ENSURE
EVERYONE MAINTAINS SIX FEET OF
SOCIAL DISTANCE. AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE WE HAVE PLENTY OF ROOM
IN THERE TO DO THAT- WE'RE ALSO-
THE SERGEANTS REJECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RULES FOR
PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION- WHICH WERE POSTED
OUTSIDE THE DOOR I ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WERE
IN ATTENDANCE TO BE AWARE OF.
AND OBSERVE THOSE RULES. PLEASE
BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
THREE OF US HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S HEARING AGENDA. WILL NOW
LOOK TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM I
DON'T BELIEVE. WHERE YET. OKAY
THEN WHAT WILL IS WE'LL MOVE TO
THE ITEMS THAT ARE LISTED- AS
OUR. FOR PRESENTATIONS TODAY.
OKAY SO WERE FIRST BILL WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP WITH MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN TWENTY ONE NINETY
SIX. MAIENSCHEIN YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR. YEAH. I THANK YOU READY
TO COME TO THE- MISTER YOU SAID
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX CORRECT
UP TO. START WITH TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX. PLEASE OKAY THANK
YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING CHARMERS AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX IS CODE CLEAN UP
REQUESTED BY THE BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ANY
WITNESSES ON THIS BILL. DOESN'T
APPEAR THAT YOU DESERVE. OKAY IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE-
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM THE LIKE
TO TESTIFY OR SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL. NAME ORGANIZATION NO
ONE HERE WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES IS THERE ANYONE ON A PHONE
OPERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WHO IS HERE TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF IN FAVOR OF TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX MAIENSCHEIN. SPEAK IN
FAVOR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. GERMAN WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP. OKAY IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE COULD COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM WHO'S HERE TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR IN A IN A OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. C. NINE. OWNER
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NAY NONE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMUNITY.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- WE'RE GOING TO
PAUSE FOR A MOMENT ABOUT THE
BELIEVE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
SECRETARY FOR CALL THE ROLL.
HOLDEN HERE. BIGELOW BRIAN.
CALDERON CORREA DOLLY DAVIES MY
FONG. VINCE FONG. APRIL EDUARDO
GARCIA LEVINE. QUOTE ARE HERE
ROBERT RIVAS WEBER. WILSON MOVE
THE BELL BILLS MOVED BY DR
COWORKERS ARE SECOND SECOND BY
DOCTOR WEBER- IN A CLOSING
COMMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR SPECTATOR QUESTION
ABOUT OKAY THE BILLS OUT ON IT-
EVEN. ON A ROLL CALL. THANK YOU
REGULATIONS. I WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK TO- THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR COULD WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED OTHER THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BE ADOPTED A SECRETARY
CAN YOU READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE DAY. CONSENT
CALENDAR AB SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
STONE. AB SIXTY NINETEEN
CERVANTES AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN COOPER AB SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE PETRIE-NORRIS A. B. C.
FORTY SIX CHAN. B. SEVENTEEN
FIFTEEN OR SU CHI AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY MURATSUCHI AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE I CAN
OCCURRING. AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN CORK AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SIX TROY A. B. EIGHTEEN OH FIVE
CHOI A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR
BOERNER HORVATH AB NINETEEN OH
SIX STONE AB NINETEEN TWENTY.
THIS A. B. T. NINE BOOK AB
TWENTY THIRTY EIGHT GIPSON AB
TWENTY FORTY EIGHT SANTIAGO AB
TWENTY ONE OH FIVE SMITH AB
TWENTY ONE. WE BETWEEN TWO ONE
TWO TWENTY. EIGHT TWENTY ONE
FIFTY EIGHT MIKE FONG AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY TWO LOW AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY NINE CARILLO. AB
TWENTY FOUR OH FOUR THREE OF US
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY TWO
MURATSUCHI AB. TWENTY FOUR TO
FORTY THREE. COOLEY AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY TWO TEN AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY TWO VALLADARES AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE LEE AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE SMITH AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN GRAY AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FIVE PATTISON
AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOURTH. IT SET
TING AB SIX VELADERO AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY THREE GABRIEL AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT-
DONALD AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO WEBER. WE DO HAVE A
PROMOTION THAT'S BEEN SECONDED-
MATTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW I BRIAN.
CALDERON CORREA MEGAN DOLLY.
MEGAN DOLLY I DAVIES. MIKE FONG.
MIKE FONG I VINCE FONG VINCE
FONG I GABRIEL EDUARDO GARCIA
LEVINE. LEVINE I WOKE. FOLK I
ROBERT RIVAS WEBER. WEBER I
WILSON WILSON I. IT SAYS
CALENDARS ADOPTED NINE ZERO
LIBERAL OPEN. WE'RE GOING TO IF
WE COULD VERY QUICKLY MR MENTION
BEFORE WE GO TO YOUR SECOND BILL
AND THEN TO MISTER BENNETT ARE
WE ARE GOING TO LOOK TO DISPENSE
WITH THE SYSTEM THE- SUSPENSE
CALENDAR MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE READ THE SUSPENSE
GALLAGHER. AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN
DAVIES. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE
WHEN AB SIXTEEN FORTY WARD AB
SIXTEEN FORTY EIGHT MAIENSCHEIN
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY FOUR GABRIEL.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY BRIAN AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT VINCE FONG
AB SIXTY NINETY TWO VOEPEL. AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN REGULAR
CURRY AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
HOLDEN. A. B. C. T. EIGHT ROBERT
RIVAS A. B. SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FIVE BRIAN AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN CORK. AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
NINE CRISTINA GARCIA AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE DALY AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO SANTIAGO. A.
B. SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR MEDINA
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX STONE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
GALLAGHER. AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
THREE COKE AB EIGHTEEN OH FOUR
SALAS AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE AGILA
CURRY. A. B. N. LEVINE AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHT JAN. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE ROBERT RIVAS
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE BERMAN
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY SIX MEDINA A.
B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY WARD A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO RAMOS A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD AB
NINETEEN NINETY HOLD NINETEEN
NINETEEN HOLDEN. AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT MCCARTY AB NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE GABRIEL AB NINETEEN
THIRTY EIGHT FRIEDMAN AB
NINETEEN FORTY TWO MURATSUCHI AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN TAKING AB
NINETEEN FORTY NINE LOW AB
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE MAIENSCHEIN
A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
LACKEY AB NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
LEE. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
ROBERT RIVAS AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN SALAS AB NINETEEN HUNDRED.
T. AROUND THE AB NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE ARAMBULA. AB NINETEEN
NINETY SIX COOLEY TWO THOUSAND
SIX BERMAN TWENTY SIXTEEN OUR
QUE HAN. TWENTY TWENTY THREE
BENNETT. TWENTY AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX FRIEDMAN AB TWENTY FORTY
MAIENSCHEIN AB TWENTY SIXTY TWO
SALAS AB TWENTY SEVENTY TWO
GABRIEL AB TWENTY SEVENTY EIGHT
FLORA AB TWENTY SEVENTY I'M WOOD
AB TWENTY NINETY FIVE KALRA AB
TWENTY ONE NINETEEN FLORA AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY WARD AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SIX FLORA AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY EIGHT COOLEY AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SIX WICKS AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN- IN. AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHT. AB TWO ONE
EIGHTY FIVE WEBER AB TWENTY TWO
OH THREE LOTS THREE OF US AB
TWENTY TWO ONE SEVENTEEN REYES.
AB TWO TWO TWO FIVE WARD AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY GIPSON AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
BOERNER HORVATH AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FOUR BLOOM AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FIVE ARAMBULA AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN REYES. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY NINE RUBIO AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO. OUR QUE
HAN AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS. AB
TWENTY THREE. I WAS A REGULAR
CURRY AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE
JONES SAWYER ON. AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY TWO NAZARIAN A. B. TWENTY
THREE SIXTY ONE MIA BONTA AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY THREE
EDUARDO GARCIA AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE DALY AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE JONES SAWYER. AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT THE
VALLAPUDUA AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
NINE CORK EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
FORTY SIX HOPEN AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE MAIENSCHEIN AB
TWENTY FIVE OH SEVEN MCCARTY AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX COOPER AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO. AB
TWENTY. SILVER AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY EIGHT IS AREA AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY TWO MCCARTY AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY TWO BENNETT AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY FIVE BLANCA RUBIO AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE
MCCARTY AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
THREE MULLIN. AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY NINE CERVANTES AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTEEN LOW AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR HOLDEN AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT BACK OKAY HAN AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY FOUR. BLANCA
RUBIO AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR PETRIE-NORRIS AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY ONE HELLO AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE LEVINE AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY FIVE PATTERSON AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE COOPER
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY FIVE
ARAMBULA. SINCE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR STATE APPROVED WILL NOW
MOVE BACK TO. MAIENSCHEIN FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION ON TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN ESTABLISHES
CONSUMER PROTECTION GUARDRAILS
FOR THE SALE OF GAP WAIVERS AND
REQUIRES THE AUTOMATIC REFUND OF
THE HONOR PREPAID WAIVER CHARGES
OF THE BILL. THEY ARE OPEN WAS
HAS BEEN TERMINAIS TERMINATE
EARLY THE BILL INSURANCE CAR
BUYERS ARE COVERED THROUGH
STRICTER CONSUMER PROTECTION
LAWS HELPING THEM AVOID THIS
COSTLY ADD ON WHEN UNNECESSARY I
APPRECIATE THE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION. WE'VE HAD WITH THE
OPPOSITION. AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM WITH ME ON THE
LINE I HAVE ANTHONY LOU ON THE
OF THE- OF JUSTICE. A RETURN TO
THE OPERATOR AT THE LOW CAN BE
CALLED FOR TO GIVE A STEP. ON
TWENTY. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN. YEAH GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS ANTHONY LIEU AND WEBER
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA AND
GET THE PROUD SPONSOR OF THE
LEGISLATION I WANT TO THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
CURRENT LEADERSHIP AND OFFERING
THE BILL- UNLIKE HER OTHER
AUTOBAHN ADD ADD ON PRODUCTS
THAT CALIFORNIA LAW DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE RIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES OF DOLLARS. AND
CONSUMERS AND GAP WAIVERS OTHER
THE THREE GENERALLY APPLICABLE
LAWS. SO WITHOUT SPECIFIC
CONSUMER PROTECTION. PACKAGES
AND MAIL AND MINISTRY AND GOT
WAIVERS. ENABLE OUR DEALER AND
LAND TO TAKE AND OF VULNERABLE
CONSUMER. HARM COMPETITION. I'LL
BE BRIEF THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY THREE OTHER STATES THAT
REGULATE GAP WE RECEIVE VARYING
DEGREES. AND ALL OF THE STATE
COULD BE CONSIDERED TO BE AHEAD
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE LACK
CLEAR CONSUMER PROTECTION. TO
MAKE THE GAP WAIVERS NOW WE WERE
ASK YOU TO VOTE I AND AB TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN TODAY THANK THAN
THAT. PROTECTIONS FOR GAP
WAIVERS THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL
TURN BACK TO ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOMS WE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY OR SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL. THE NINE
WILL GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES
ARE THERE ANY OTHER. ANYONE
ONLINE. A PHONE OPERATOR WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON THIS
BILL NAME. ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. ONLY TO COME INTO THIS
BILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. TWO
GERMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME OKAY WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK IN A HOP TO
THE BILL. BEFORE. HELLO MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SHE MAIENSCHEIN A
GENERATOR HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT AFFECTING THE
AVAILABILITY OF WHAT WE VIEW AS
A IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
PRODUCT IN THE STATE BUT WE HAVE
HAD VERY PER PATIENT WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THOSE THANKS VERY
GOOD. CNO OTHER WE WILL TURN TO
THE PHONE LINE AND- RECOGNIZE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE A
COMMENT OPPOSITION NAME.
ORGANIZATION A POSITION.
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. GERMAN KNOWN AS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
A MOTION THAT'S BEEN SECOND IT
IS- ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS OR-
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SAY NONE OF
THOSE OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU. AND ALL. OF MISTER BENNETT
. I'M SORRY- A SERVICE TO
BENNETT WITH BENNETT JUST ONE
SECOND WE HAVE THIS REYES. FOR
WORKING THROUGH THE PROCESS ARE
MY OF MY APOLOGIES KANSEN SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE BONUS REYES.
IS- TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. A
TO PROTECT WORKERS DURING THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC I
AUTHORED AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE AND
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY FOUR WHICH
REQUIRED EMPLOYERS TO ROOT
REPORT. HOPE IT NINETEEN
WORKPLACE OUTBREAKS TO THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND NOTIFY
WORKERS OF A COVERT NINETEEN
EXPOSURE IN THE WORKPLACE MOVE
THE BILL AB TWO TWENTY SIX
NINETY THREE SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
SUNSET OF THESE PROVISIONS FROM
JANUARY. ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE A NEW VERY AS NEW
VARIANTS SPREAD BECAUSE
ADDITIONAL SEARCHES IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS CRITICAL THAT
OUR WORKERS ARE AWARE OF ANY
EXPOSURES IN THE WORKPLACE. THE
COST OF THE BILL ARE MINOR AND
MOBILE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS CHASSIS GROUP GROW.
BY DIRECTOR FOR THE U. F. C. W.
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JESSE GRANT
WHILE HERE ON BEHALF OF U. F. C.
W. WESTERN STATES COUNCIL AND
ARE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
FRONTLINE ESSENTIAL WORKERS. IN
THE FOOD PHARMACEUTICAL AND
RETAIL SECTORS ALL OF HIM HAVE
SERVED THEIR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC WITH
GREAT RISK TO THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. CALIFORNIA IS
MOVING TOWARDS A NEW PHASE AND
THE COVER NINETEEN FIGHT THAT
PLACES TESTING VACCINATION AND
SUPPORT FRONT AND CENTER. A. B.
SIX EIGHTY FIVE TRACKING GIVES A
STATE KEY DATA ON WORKPLACE
OUTBREAK SO WE CAN FOCUS OUR
RESOURCES EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY TO STOP. AT OF
COVERED NINETEEN. AB TWO SIX
NINE THREE ONE SURE THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE KEPT IN PLACE AS
COVER NINETEEN VARIANTS CONTINUE
TO AFFECT CALIFORNIA. AND FUTURE
VARIANTS CAN SHOW UP AT ANY TIME
FOR THESE REASONS AND MORE WE
RESPECT. REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY ON AB TWO SIX NINE THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO. AT SUPPORT.
TO THIS BILL. SAY NINE WILL TURN
TO THE PHONE LINES PHONE
OPERATORS OR ANYONE ONLINE I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE. TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF TWENTY SIX
NINETY THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
CHEWING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER.
WILL OPEN NINE FORTY ONE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN NUMBERS
OUT WHELAN- SOME OF NAPA'S HERE
ON BEHALF OF YEAH YOU'D ACT
NOTED NURSES CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ILLUSIONS YOU AT THIS
TIME IT COMING BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM ANYONE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THEY NINE PHONE
OPERATOR WILL RECEIVE ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION
THAT THIS IS. PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TWO GERMAN WE HAVE
NO ACUTE. WE WILL- BRING IT BACK
TO THE- MANY OF THIS YEAR WE
HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK IS
THEIR SECOND. SEKHEMRE DR WEBER. REYES WILL TURN TO YOU FOR ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE THIS IS OUT
ON THE B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE VICE HERE'S GOING TO PRESENT
ON BEHALF OF MR COOLEY. OF THIS
IS FOR AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE VICE CHAIR SPELL. I WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE IT'S THANK YOU
MOVED AND SECONDED A MOTION AND
A SECOND. I JUST WANT TO SAY MR
COOLEY WASN'TABLE TO BE HERE
BECAUSE HE'S HOME ILL TODAY AND
HE'S BEEN OUT ALL WEEK ANY
STITCHES. APOLOGIES FOR SUCH I
HAVE A LENGTHY- PRESENTATION
HERE BUT- IF YOU ALL WOULD LIKE
I KNOW HOW LONG OUR DAY IS
STRUCTURED SO I'D JUST LIKE TO.
MOVE THIS ALONG- WE DO HAVE A
WITNESS- JOHN NORWOOD WHO IS IN
PERSON IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD.
SNORT THE ON THE FLOOR. I'M A
ROOKIE OF THE SORRY- MISTER
CHAIRMAN GERMAN MEMBERS JOHN
NORWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE COUNTY
ASSOCIATION THIS BILL DOES MAKE
THREE QUICK CLEAN UP CHANGES IN
THE STATUTES GOVERNING THAT
ASSOCIATION EMERGES TO BONDING
AUTHORITIES- CLARIFIES THAT
CYBER INSURANCES COVERED AS A
COVERED CLAIM AND ALSO ENSURES
THAT- EACH INSURER IS SUBJECT TO
THE SAME SURCHARGE- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO LEND THEIR SUPPORT. THIS BILL
THEY NOW I'M OWNER OPERATOR WILL
ENTERTAIN THOSE WHO ARE ONLINE I
WOULD LIKE TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION OF. FOR TWENTY ONE
FIFTY FOUR. TO EXPRESS PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. GERMAN
WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SINAN PHONE OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. DO CHAIR
WE HAVE KNOWN CUED UP. BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE WE HAVE A MOTION
ANY COMMENTS OR THOUGHTS. THIS
BILL IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. MISTER
BENNETT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE OH NINE
WILL PROHIBITIVELY WERE ANIL
DESHMUKH THE MAIL FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ATTRACTING WERE
VIEWING WHITE SHARKS ALSO THE
DEPARTMENT- MY ARE MINOR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
. DO YOU HAVE ANYONE IS A MAIN
WILL WITNESSES OKAY IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THE NINE PHONE OPERATOR WILL
TAKE SUPPORT- COMMENTS. OR
ANYONE ONLINE. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO ACUTE UP
MISTER CHAIR MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU WERE BACK IN THE HEARING
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION. THE NON
OWNER OPERATOR ANYONE ONLINE FOR
OPPOSITION. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO GERMAN WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE COULD UP OKAY
WILL BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
SAY NO COMMENTS THIS BILL IS OUT
ON A. B. ROLL CALL. IT'S A
MINUTE YOU HAVE A SECOND BILL
TWENTY ONE SIXTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY WOULD
REDUCE THE COST OF PROCESSING
TIME FOR NGOS. SEEKING MIRABEL.
WORK FOR PUBLIC ACCESS OR
RESTORATION PROJECTS ALLOWING A
SEIZING COUNTIES TO WAIVER
REDUCE COST DEVELOPMENT PERMIT.
FOSTER MINOR- AND ABSORB ALL THE
TO THE COMMISSION RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. SAY NONE WILL TURN TO
THE PHONE OPERATOR WE WERE
ENTERTAINING. OF SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. OF TWENTY ONE SIXTY.
SPEAKING SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE SHOULD
UP ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THE NON OWNER
OPERATOR WILL. OPPOSITION.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY. SPEAKING PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN
CUED UP BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THIS IS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR BERMAN.
TWENTY SIX OH EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER JR AND COLLEAGUES LAST
YEAR BUILDING UPON THE SUCCESS
OF OUR SAFE AND SECURE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTYELECTION I
AUTHORED LEGISLATION TO SEND
EVERY ACTIVE REGISTERED VOTER A
BALLOT BY MAIL FOR ALL FUTURE
ELECTIONS IN WHICH THE VOTERS
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE MOVE THE BILL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL- GOOD- NO
WITNESSES. NO OKAY. ARE WE WILL
LOOK TO ANYONE IN THEHEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF TWENTY SIX AWAY
BERMAN. THE RARE YOURS HERE ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY STATE DOT
SHIRLEY WEBER SPORT SPONSORED
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
SEE NO OTHER SPEAKERS- FOR
SUPPORT WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES PHONE OPERATOR ANYONE
ONLINE I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WE DO HAVE A LINE QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER.
WE WILL OPEN UP LINE TWENTY TWO
GO AHEAD. HI RYAN ROCCO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS PLAYED OF
MIDIAN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE INTO THIS TIME SIR. IN THE
HEARING ROOM IS THERE ANYONE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IT'S A NON
OWNER OPERTOR WILL. ON ANYONE
ONLINE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY SIX AWAIT. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A LINE
QUEUING UP ONE MOBILE WALLET
PROVIDER LINE NUMBER.
WE WILL TOPLINE FORTY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI THIS IS
GABRIELLE IN GRANDSTAND AT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
TO BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S OF AN EMOTION A SECOND.
OF THIS A BILL IS OUT ON A BILL
B. ROLL CALL. THANK YOUNG.
REMEMBER RUBIO. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY THREE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT A B. TWO TWENTY ONE
SIXTY THREE OUT WHICH EXTENDS
THE SUNSET FOR THE CENTER BASE
AND WATER QUALITY OF THIRTY W.
Q. WAY TO THE YEAR OF TWENTY
FIFTY THE PROJECTS UNDERTAKEN BY
THE O. W. Q. EIGHT TO REMEDIATE
OUR COMMUNITY'S GROUNDWATER THIS
IS A PAID AN EXTENSION ON THIS
MEASURE HAS MAKE NEGLIGIBLE
STATE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOT. MOVING THE BILL. BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED. NO
WITNESSES. A WITNESS HI IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
THE NON PHONE OPERATOR- ANYONE
ONLINE I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF TWENTY ONE SIXTY THREE
. TO SPEAK IN FAVOR PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
LINES IN Q. MISTER CHAIRMAN.
ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE NO LINES IN
Q. HEARING ROOM- OPPOSITION. THE
NINE PHONE OPERATOR ANYONE
ONLINE FOR OPPOSITION. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE NINE ZERO.
WE DO HAVE A LINE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER.
WE WILL OPEN UP LINE FORTY NINE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHECK WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE SINGLE BASIN WATER QUALITY
AUTHORITY AND- SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL SO THAT THE
AGENCY CAN CONTINUE TO WORK TO
CLEAN UP THE MAIN SAN DIEGO
BASED RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL
. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. GOOD- THIS. BILL HAS
A MOTION AND A SECOND. OF THIS
BILL IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
MISTER SALAS. YOU HAVE TO BILLS
A SIXTEEN FORTY TWO IN NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ARE PROUD TO
PRESENT SIMPLY BILL SIXTEEN
FORTY TWO WHICH WILL STREAMLINE
VITAL WATER WELL PROJECTS TO
MITIGATE OR PREVENT FAILURE OF A
DRINKING WATER WELL THAT IS
DESIGNATED AS HIGH RISK OR
MEDIUM RISK BY THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. IT'S
BEEN MOVED AS THEIR SECOND.
THERE'S A SECOND IS THERE ANYONE
NO WITNESSES AND DIFFERENCE HERE
COMMITTEES TIME NO WITNESSES
OKAY- I SEE NO ONE HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL ONLINE
PHONE OPERATOR ANYONE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN
IN Q. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. HEARING NONE ON
OPERATOR OPPOSITION TO SIXTEEN
FORTY TWO. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
YOU HAVE NO LINES IN Q. MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THIS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
SIX NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THANK
YOU THE SHERIN PROFFERS AN
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE- WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE PROPOSING
THE JAIL SYNTHESIS PRODUCTS IN A
RESPONSIBLE FASHION RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGHT. MOTION THERE'S A
SECOND IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM THEY WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR SAME NON OWNER
OPERATOR SUPPORT ONLINE. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q.
MISTER CHAIRMAN. ANYONE IN THE
FULL IN THE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OR OPERATOR
OPPOSITION. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. HELLO LINE'S
QUEUING UP BOB PARDON ME WE DO
HAVE ONE LINE CHEWING UP ONE
MOMENT WHILE THE PROVIDER LINE
NUMBER.
WE WILL OPEN NINE FIFTY THREE GO
AHEAD. FIVE WELL I OPPOSED SB
SEVENTY NINE AND I THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE MORE THAN A FEW
SECONDS TO TALK. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES AND YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE DIFFERENCE OKAY.
THANK YOU OF WE HAVE THIS
THERE'S A MOTION FOR THIS BILL-
IT'S OUT WITH DEMOCRATS VOTING I
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOAT BUILDERS TO
THINK CHANGES DEFINITION TO
TRAVEL LANDS AND EXTENDS A
SUNSET VERY GOOD- NO WITNESSES
HERE ON AB TWENTY EIGHTY ONE. WE
HAVE- SOMEONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. WE'RE NOT
YEARS. HAVE A GAME. OKAY I'LL
TRY THAT REAL QUICK APPEAL ARE
NOT TAKING TIME TO HEAR FOR THE
BROAD BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
JUST HERE AS GRATEFUL SPONSORS
IN STRONG SUPPORTERS ARE DO
SUPPORT THANK YOU. VERY GOOD. I
SEE NO ONE ELSE OF APPROACHING
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR PHONE
OPERATORS ANYONE ONLINE I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB
TWENTY EIGHTY ONE. TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE DO
HAVE A LINE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBER.
WE WILL OPEN LINE FORTY GO AHEAD
. YES THE- CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PUBLIC TREAT ON BEHALF
OF THE CHUNGA AND THE COLUSA
TRIED- WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTING. WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINES IN Q.
OKAY WE'LL LOOK TO ANYONE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. THEY NINE PHONE
OPERATOR. IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE
TO VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY EIGHTY ONE. TO VOICE YOUR
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
WE DO HAVE A LINE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBER. WE WILL GO TO LINE
FIFTY FIVE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS SYDNEY HOFF WAS REMOVED ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSE UPPER LAKE
AND CAN HEAR IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINES
INTO THIS TIME. OKAY WE WILL
TURN THE C. MAKE SURE NO ONE'S
IN OPPOSITION. ONLINE OPERATOR
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO ALLIES IN
QUEUE THIS TIME SIR VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION
THAT'S BEEN SECONDED THIS IS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. SO REMEMBER
CALDERON. TWENTY FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FORTY TWO WOULD ESTABLISH
A WELLNESS VENDING MACHINE PILOT
PROGRAM AT COLLEGE CAMPUSES
ACROSS THE STATE MOVE THE BILL
TO ENSURE STUDENTS HAVE
SUFFICIENT ACCESS TO DISCOUNTED
HEALTH AND WELLNESS PRODUCTS
OUTSIDE PHARMACY HOURS WITHOUT
NEEDING TO LEAVE THEIR CAMPUS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU. OF THE WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES NO WITNESSES- I SEE NO
ONE THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ON
OPERATOR. WILL ENTERTAIN SUPPORT
COMMENTS. TWO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTY GO AHEAD. I BRING A GALLON
FROM I DON'T THINK OVERLOOKED IN
INCREMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THE NINE OPPOSITION ONLINE. THE
TWENTY FORTY TWO. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO LINE'S
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIRMAN. VERY
GOOD. THIS IS GOING TO PROCEED
IN MOTION A SECOND. THIS IS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MR FLOOR. TWENTY ONE
OH SEVEN. MOVE THE BELL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU STAFF
WILL MAKE THIS VERY VERY QUICK-
I JUST THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WERE OF HER HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL AB TWENTY ONE OF SEVERAL
PERMIT THOSE WHO ARE LICENSED TO
CONDUCT CONDUCT AN ACTIVE
MOLECULAR TESTING FOR HUMAN
GENETICS. YOU ALSO DO IT FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASE I DON'T MAKE
IT HAS AN EASIER FOR THOSE ARE
UNABLE TO SELL SWAP I'VE GOT
THAT JUSTIN ADVANCE- HERE PRETTY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF NEEDED
THE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. VERY
GOOD WE. THANKS A GOOD MORNING
JUST ADVANCE ON BEHALF OF HE
LOOKS A CALIFORNIA BASED HUMAN
GENOMICS COMPANY WERE THE PROUD
SPONSORS THE BILL WE'RE HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE
ANY THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
FIELDING GRAVES BY UPON
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WAS FLOOR
I WAS TOLD BY THE MINORITY
LEADER THAT. LAST YEAR THAT WE
SHOULD PROBABLY NOT CONSIDER
YOUR BILL BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
A TIE ON THIS. I WOULD EXPECT
NOTHING LESS. BUT NOTICE I'M
SWEATING SO I RAN HERE'S LIKE A
TESTIFIED. WITH NO WORD IS WELL
DONE SIR. I DO WE HAVE- SUPPORT
ONLINE. FOR TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO LINES INTO MISTER CHAIRMAN
CLIPLESS HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION
. C. NINE ONLINE PHONE OPERATOR
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY ONE OH
SEVEN. SPEAKING OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. HAVE
NO LINES IN Q. SCENE NO COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE- AND NOT
WITHSTANDING YOU DON'T HAVE A
TÀI OUT ON A ROPE. WE APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR. MIKE
FONG IF YOU'RE READY. AB TWENTY
NINE SEVENTEEN. MOVE THE BELL.
FOR THE SECOND AB SO MUCH OF THE
MORNING SO CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINE
ONE SEVEN IS ABOUT COLLECTING
INFORMATION ON LITIGATION ON
WEBSITE ACCESSIBILITY GIVEN
BUSINESSES HELPFUL INFORMATION
ON AVOIDING SUCH LITIGATION
ATTORNEY INVOLVED IN SUCH CASES
REPORT SPECIFIED INFORMATION TO
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY MISSION
ON DISABILITY ACCESS REQUIRE THE
COMMISSION TO PREPARE
EDUCATIONAL MATERIAL WEBSITE
ACCESSIBILITY STANDARDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR TYPE OF.
THANK YOU. SEEING UP NO ONE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM
THAT- IS GOING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WE WILL TURN THE PHONE
LINES. BUT OPERATOR TWENTY WHAT
TWENTY NINE SEVENTEEN. COURT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TWO GERMAN WE
HAVE NO LINES IN Q. IN SUPPORT.
M. OPPOSITION THE NINE IN
OPPOSITION I WOULD TURN THE
PHONE LINES IS THERE OPPOSITION
ONLINE FOR TWENTY NINE
SEVENTEEN. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO LINE'S QUEUED UP-
THIS BILL AS A MOTION A SECOND
DO PASS- IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH- THE RIVER DOLLY NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY
SERGEANTS WILL ASK YOU IF YOU
COULD START TO CALL AUTHORS TO
BILLS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN PRESENT.
OKAY.
YEAH.
OKAY WE WILL- NOW HERE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE BY
REMEMBER JONES SAWYER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT WITH THE TIE O AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE MOVE WITH
L. WHICH CREATES AT
ALTERNATIVELY FOR INDIVIDUALS
CHARGED WAS MESSED UP BY DRUG
OFFENSES WHILE MAINTAINING THE
SAME EXPOSURE CRIMINAL PENALTIES
PROSECUTORS WILL HAVE DISCRETION
OFFERED THIS ALTERNATIVE ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS AND ONLY AT
THE REQUEST OF THE DEFENSE
COUNSEL THE BILL HAS NO
ADDITIONAL COST AND HELPS KEEP
COURTS RUNNING EFFICIENTLY BY
ALLOWING EARLY RESOLUTION OF
CASES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. ABOUT. AS DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES SHOW THAT YOU DO I
DO BUT I THINK WE'RE GONNA GONNA
DO ME TO IT DAVE THAT'S FINE
THAT'S FINE SO WE'LL ENTERTAIN
ANYONE WHO IS IN THE HEARING
ROOM THEY WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL. ONLY ST
LOUIS ON BEHALF OF DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER AND INITIATE
JUST JUSTICE ALL PROUD CO
SPONSORS. ATTESTED SEE NO OTHER-
PERSON PER PAIR TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL IN THE HEARING
ROOM WILL TURN TO ONLINE PHONE
OPERATOR SUPPORT ON TWENTY ONE
NINETY FIVE. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO IN
QUEUED UP. OPPOSITION SAN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM
WILL TURN TO ONLINE PHONE
OPERATOR OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
ONE NINETY FIVE. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
WE HAVE NO LINE'S QUEUED UP
MISTER CHAIRMAN. IT BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SEEING NO
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE-
THIS ENTERTAINS. ENJOYS A DO
PASS IT'S OUT ON A THE ROLL CALL
. THANK YOU.
SO. ZERO DONALD WE WILL-
PRESENTATION IF YOU'RE READY.
DESIGN AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SIX
WHICH WILL GROW. GOOD EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BY GIVING
BOTH PARTIES ADDITIONAL TIME TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT BEFORE A
PUBLIC AGENCY IMPOSES THEIR LAST
BEST AND FINAL OFFER. UNDER
CURRENT LAW AFTER MEDIATION OR
FACT FINDING PARTIES ARE ONLY
GIVEN TEN DAYS TO REACT TO THOSE
FINDINGS RESOLVE THE REMAINING
ISSUES OF CONTROVERSY OF
CONTROVERSY BEFORE THE PUBLIC
AGENCY CAN IMPOSE AGAIN THEIR
LAST BEST AND FINAL OFFER. AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SIX SEEKS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FIVE DAYS FOR
PARTIES TO MEET TO DISCUSS THE
FACT FINDER'S REPORT AND WORK
TOWARDS AN AGREEMENT. IN HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE BILL'S
DOUG SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS MISTER CHAIR. VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DOUG SERVERS AND WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS PLEASED O BE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE FIVE
SIX TODAY. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL NOTED IMPASSE
PROCEDURES AT THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARDS ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY FOR FIREFIGHTERS
WHO ARE STATUTORILY PROHIBITED
FROM STRIKING SHOULD THEY REACH
AN IMPASSE WITH THEIR EMPLOYER
SO ADDING FIVE DAYS AFTER THE
FACT FINDER'S REPORT FOR A FULL
FIFTEEN DAYS OF DISCUSSION
BETWEEN THE BARGAINING UNIT IN
THE EMPLOYEE. HOPEFULLY RESOLVE.
A DISAGREEMENT BEFORE LAST BEST
AND FINAL OFFER IS IMPOSED IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THE NON PHONE
OPERATOR ANYONE ONLINE I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SIX. THIS WEEK
IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO LIVES
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIRMAN-
THROUGH THE HEARING ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK
OPPOSITION. NAY NONE PHONE
OPERATOR OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY SIX. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. DON'T MIND QUEUING
UP MISTER CHAIRMAN OKAY BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THERE'S A MOTION-
DO PASS IS THE MOTION- THIS IS
OUT ON A- REPUBLICANS DEMOCRATS
VOTING HI REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
WITH THIS DAVIS VOTING HIGH.
REGULATIONS ARE YOU MISTER. OKAY
THAT'S WHEN A SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. SENATE ENJOYS A DO PASS
AS AMENDED MOVE THE BELL. THANK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WHICH
BILL SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU HAVE A THE FIFTY EIGHT
SUPPORT- AS- ACTUALLY A MAKE IT
SIMPLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. THE- A SIMPLE THANK YOU-
SEEING THAT NO ONE. AND YOU HAVE
NO WITNESSES. OF WE WILL SEE NO
ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. OWNER OPERATOR WILL
ENTERTAIN SUPPORT. FOR SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. SPEAKING SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BLINDS IN CUBA'S CHAIRMAN.
ALLIANCE SECURITY CERTIFICATE
OKAY THANK YOU SO WE'LL COME
BACK ONLINE TO OKAY SO WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM
ANY OPPOSITION THE OPPOSITION
GROUP. DR WORK. I JUST WANT TO
SAY YOUR TWO BILLS ARE RIGHT
EXCELLENT THERE JUST WHAT WE
NEED TO PROTECT PEOPLE OF THE
STATE THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
OTHER MEMBERS. THIS IS A TO DO
PASSED AS AMENDED ITS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
IT'S ALSO ENJOYS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. IS ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM SAYING
NINE PHONE OPERATOR WE'RE
ENTERTAINING SUPPORT SIXTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. TWENTY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. MISTER CHAIRMAN OPPOSITION.
THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM SAY
NONE OPPOSITION ONLINE. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO LINE'S
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIRMAN- WE'RE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THE
SENATE DESTROYS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED. THE NO COMMENTS
REMEMBERS ITS OUT ON OR A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU.
WE ARE STILL LOOKING FOR WORK
BOERNER HORVATH. FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL KALRA THREE OF US WILL
BE HERE AT TEN FIFTEEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS FRIEDMAN
MORNING WE'RE HERE TO HEAR AB
NINETEEN OH NINE. ENJOYS A DO
PASS. MOVING THE BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ESTIMATES THAT THIS
BILL WILL HAVE A NEGLIGIBLE
STATE COST OF ANY AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TO HELP WITH A
CYCLIST TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A
CLEAN AND HEALTHY MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD. I SEE NO ONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
RETURN OF THE PHONE LINES PHONE
OPERATOR WERE ENTERTAINED
SUPPORT ON NINETEEN OH NINE. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A
LINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE DEADLINE NUMBER.
OPEN LINE TWELVE. SHAREHOLDING
THE MEMBERS JAMES MARTIN JUNIOR
DEPTH CALIFORNIA SUFFICIENT BY
THING ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THE NEXT LINE FORTY
FIVE. ACCORDING TO CITY WALK ON
GOT THE ONLY COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE CALGARY BICYCLE WHICH WOULD
SUPPORT. I HAVE NO FOR THE LINES
INTO IT THIS TIME. I TURNED TO
HEAR ROOM OPPOSITION SEE NON.
OWNER OPERATOR OPPOSITION ONLINE. TO NINETEEN OH NINE. TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
ARE NO LINES INTO MISTER
CHAIRMAN. RIGHT BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY DOCTOR QUIRK IS MADE A
MOTION IS OUR SECOND. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND- CALDERON AS A
SECOND ABOUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
WELCOME I KNOW YOU'RE ORDERING
THE RIGHT MOVE AVAIL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE THIS
IS A DO PASS- AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY THREE WE WILL TURN AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PHONE
OPERATOR SUPPORT ONLINE. FOR
TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE. THE
PART PART TWENTY FOUR NINETY
THREE PRESS TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
NINETY THREE. TWENTY FIVE NINETY
THREE SUPPORT ONE ZERO. NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. YOUR IN ROOM OPPOSITION
THE NINE PHONE LINE OPPOSITION
TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE.
ATTENTION TWENTY FIVE NINETY
THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
L'APPLICATION AT THIS TIME. I'M
SORRY. YOU HAVE NO ONE ONLINE IS
THAT WHAT YOU SAID. OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME TO RICHARD THAT OF
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE AS A
DO PASS MOTION IT'S BEEN
SECONDED. IT'S OUT OF B. ROLL
CALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY. MEMBERS- MR FONG S. TWIST
MY ARM TO ALLOW HIMSELF TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF MR GABRIEL
I'VE YIELDED TO HIS REQUEST. AND
SO HE WILL BE PRESENTING AB TWO
THOUSAND. THIS WAS ORIGINALLY A
CONSENT ITEM BILL. MOVE THE BELL
. HUB AND THIS MOTION IS TO PASS
AB TWO THOUSAND. YOU PLEASE
INTRODUCE IF YOU'D LIKE A
MIXTURE MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ON MY ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE AS A MEMBER GABRIEL AB
TWO THOUSAND INCREASES-
PENALTIES FOR SIDESHOWS. MISTER
BASS FOR ABOUT. WE'LL TURN TO
YOUR STAR WITNESS AND SEE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. ASK AT ANY CHANCE
YOU GET RUN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE WAS TURN TO ANYONE
WHO'S HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THAT'S BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
RIGHT THERE. OUR PHONE OPERATOR
SUPPORT FOR TWO THOUSAND AB TWO
THOUSAND. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT NO LOGIC YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN HEARING THE HEARING
ROOM OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
PHONE LINE OPPOSITION AB TWO
THOUSAND. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q.
IT WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THIS IS A MOTION
SECONDED. WILL TURN TO DR QUIRK
QUESTION JAAP- I THINK. SO THE
ACLU IS AGAINST THIS I THINK
MISTAKENLY SO. ARE THERE
CLAIMING IT CREATES A NEW CRIME
WHICH COURSE WOULD ADD COSTS. I
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IS THE CASE-
YOUR BILL WOULD SIMPLY SAY IF
YOU'RE PARKED OFF STREET. WHEN
THERE IS A- OUR NEXT EXHIBITION
OF- SPEED TO OUR RECIPE
CONTESTS. THAT- THAT'S A PLACE
WHERE IT IS ILLEGAL TO BE
BECAUSE YOU ARRIVE SUPPORTING OF
THE SPEED CONTEST WHICH IS SO
DANGEROUS THIS IS MERELY
ENFORCEMENT OF AN EXISTING CRIME
AND I THEREFORE THINK THAT THE
ACLU IS WRONG IN THINKING THAT
THIS WOULD INCREASE COSTS. I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU JUST
SAID. IN OTHER COMMENTS- THIS
BILL IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
APOLOGIES GOT A BUSY HEARING
HOUSING WE KNOW HOW IT HOW IT IS. WE WILL GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
OR CONSENT FOR ADD ONS MISS
GABRIEL. IF YOU'D LIKE TO JOIN
IN ADDING ONTO AND SAID WORLD IN
THE ROLE FOR THAT. CONSENT
CALENDAR BRIAN. CALDERON.
CALDERON I. CORREA. DAVIES
DAVIES I. GABRIEL GABRIEL I
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I.
WE'RE NOW WAITING FOR TO AUTHORS
MISTER KALRA WHO I UNDERSTAND IS
PRESENTING AND ANOTHER COMMITTEE
AND MISS RIVAS WHO WAS ON HER
WAY TO THIS HEARING.
SIGEBERHT WHILE YOU'RE HERE I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAD A NOT
VOTING ON AB SIXTEEN FORTY TWO
SALAS. AB SIXTEEN FORTY TWO
GABRIEL NOT VOTED.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE DOCTOR
QUIRK PRESENT- COVERED UP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AS BILL
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN WHICH ENJOYS
IT TO PASS MISTER KALRA IS. AND
COMMITTEE IT MAY BE A WHILE
BEFORE YOU CAN BREAK AWAY SO A
DOCTOR QUIRK IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PRESENT YES AB R. TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN ESTABLISHES CALIFORNIA
POCKET FORCED INITIATIVE WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION. REQUIRES CAL
FIRE TO CREATE- CREATE
GUIDELINES FOR PLANTING POCKET
FORESTS AND PROVIDES GRANTS TO
CITIES COUNTIES DISTRICT
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO CREATE POCKET
FORCE ON PUBLIC LAND. I ASK THE
ARRIVAL OKAY. ENJOYS A DO PASS-
GARCIA MOVES AND MR FONG SECOND
. WE WILL TURN TO ANYONE IN A
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR THE
BILL. THE NINE WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES PHONE OPERATORS
SUPPORT. A TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
OUR- TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PENALIZING YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I WILL BRING BACK TO THE HEARING
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION SYRIAN NINE
PHONE OPERATOR OPPOSITION. THE
TWENTY ONE FOR SPEAKING
OPPOSITION. TO SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THE TIME. WHAT YOU MISTER
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE THE
LINES IN Q. OKAY THERE'S A
MOTION IT'S BEEN SECOND IT'S DO
PASS. SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS THIS
IS ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH THIS
DOLLY NOT VOTING AND MISS DAVIES
VOTING I.
YEAH.
ON THE LONG.
WELCOME MOVE THE BILL AND
WELCOME BACK. SO WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE FIRST BILL WHICH IS A. B.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY TWO TO DO PASSED
AS AMENDED AND THERE'S A MOTION
TO. WHAT THE BILL IS OUR SECOND
. AND SECOND IT. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR OF AB
THIRTY TWO THIRTY TWO WOULD
PROHIBIT SEABED MINING IN STATE
MARINE WATERS DUE TO A HIGH RISK
OF DAMAGE AND DISRUPTION OPPOSES
TO THE STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. IS THERE A
WITNESS THAT YOU HAVE TO TESTIFY
- OKAY. ALSO FELT I DID SEE HER
SORRY YES WAS A WITNESS OR JUST
TO AT THE VERY BRIEF OKAY THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF SURFRIDER FOUNDATION
IN THE MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM OR
THE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY TWO AND WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM OF LIKE TO
TESTIFY OR SPEAK IN FAVOR. THE
NINE OWNER OPERATOR WE'RE
ENTERTAINING SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTEEN THIRTY TWO. SO TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IT'LL OPEN UP NINE SEVENTY
FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
YES- NOT. GIVE ME A SECOND HERE
. SO I'M CALLING TO TESTIFY THAT
I AM WHAT WAS CALIFORNIA ON BAIL
AB TWENTY TWO READY TO WE'RE NOT
ENTERTAINING THAT THIS IS
EIGHTEEN THIRTY TWO. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE FOURTEEN. THE
MORNING ACTUALLY GLICO DRINKER
WITH OCEANIA AND SUPORT THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE OVER
THE LINES INTO. EVERY ROOM
OPPOSITION SEE NON OWNER
OPERATOR OPPOSITION TO EIGHTEEN
THIRTY TWO. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
FERTILIZING CHEMIST CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU WE COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THERE'S BEEN IN MOTION
DO PASS AS AMENDED OF THIS IS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- NOW YOU'RE GOING 2%
A. B. A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE WOULD
MAKE CLIMATE CHANGE OF COURSE
REQUIREMENT FOR GRADES ONE
THROUGH TWELVE SO THAT OUR
FUTURE LEADERS CAN GAIN THE
KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE. THE
CIVICALLY APRIL NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE WOULD ENSURE THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE EDUCATION IS TAUGHT IN
OUR SCHOOLS BY REQUIRING THE
APPROPRIATE COURSE WORK TO BE
OFFERED TO STUDENTS NO LATER
THAN. THE SCHOOL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
BY CALDERON SECOND BY DAVIES- IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
. FOR THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
SUPPORT ON AB EIGHT NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE. AN OPERATOR
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE SUPPORT.
PARDON ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE WILL OPEN LINE TWENTY SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROUGHLY ON
CAPITOL STREET SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
NO FURTHER LINES IN Q. HEARING
ROOM OPPOSITION. TINO OPPOSITION
PHONE LINE OPERATOR OPPOSITION
TO NINETEEN THIRTY NINE. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
ARE NO LINES INTO MISTER
CHAIRMAN. OKAY IT'S BEEN IN
MOTION DO PASSED. MOTION AND
THIS IS OUT- WITH DEMOCRATS
VOTING I REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
WITH MISTER BIGELOW VOTING NOW
AND MISS DAVIES FORTY NINE OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT CONCLUDES OUR-
PRESENTATIONS OF BILLS WE'RE
GONNA NOW MOVE TO- OPEN UP THE
HEARING- TO COMMENTS BY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ON ANY BILL NOT
PRESENTED TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. OF PLEASE BE SURE TO
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND YOU'RE
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL. THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO STATE THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE TELEPHONE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO STATE THEIR POSITION ON.
A BILL THAT WAS ON OUR CALENDAR
FOR TODAY. TO SPEAK ON ANY BILL
AT THIS POINT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WILL FIRST OPEN UP
LINE SEVENTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE
. GOOD MORNING THIS IS ROBERT
GORE FROM THE GLOCAL GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN GABRIEL BASIN
WATER QUALITY OF SORTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO ONE SIX THREE WE ARE
COSPONSORED. THANK YOU. I'M.
FIFTY SEVEN. WHAT ABOUT MOBILE
WITHOUT THE PUBLIC LOCAL IRVINE
BUT THE DEMOCRATIC. FOR MATHIS
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY. FINALIZAR MARKET THAT
ABOUT BONTA SAID POLITICAL THE
HOPE OF WINDOWS BUT THAT AND
FOUND THE OF A LARGE WITH I
REQUEST BOB- WITH THE WAY OFTEN
. APPLE NOT I'M GLAD THANKS. FOR
THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY ONE.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOUG EVAN I
MEAN A CO OF INDUCED UP NOT
AMERICA FROM FEMA GALA I OPPOSE
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO OKAY
BECAUSE OF THEY COULD TO ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION HIM TO THE
BIG THING JAMES THEY HATE SYMBOL
THAT ACTUALLY SYMBOL OF TALKING
. I DON'T AND THE BILL SHOULD BE
AND AT BATCH THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY TWO. HELLO I'M A MY UP
YOUR YES GO AHEAD YES OKAY IMY
NAME IS KRISTA NORMA I'M CALLING
A PRIVATE LAND- OWNERS CONCERNS
THE AND TIMES SO AND- VMA THAT
OPPOSITION AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN HAS NOT HAD ANY
DETAILED ANALYSIS NO SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE OR LEGAL FRAMEWORK- PUT
FORTH I'M SORRY THAT MORE WAS
THE BILL'S NOT BEFORE US TODAY.
IT WOULD NEXT DOOR THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE THE FIRST ONE AT
NINE O'CLOCK IT WAS LISTED AND
WAS IT'S NOT ON OUR CALENDAR I'M
SORRY. THAT WAS NOT ON OUR
CALENDAR. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
THIRTY SIX. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT-
THAT MY APOLOGIES. THE I. BEFORE
YOU BEFORE YOU GO FORWARD WE CAN
THAT WAS ONE OF OUR SUSPENSE.
GALLAGHER ITEM SO IS MY APOLOGY
TO THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER SO- IF
SHE'S STILL ON WE WILL COME BACK
TO HER. AND GIVE HER AN
OPPORTUNITY FINISHER HER
COMMENTS. THAT THE SPEAKER WHO'S
ON NOW WILL GO AHEAD AND HEAR
YOUR THOUGHTS. THANK YOU SO MY
NAME IS ABOUT THAT AND M. IT.
AARON FROM ROSIE. I OPPOSE CA AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO WHICH- THE
SPECTACLE BECAUSE OF THE
SOPHISTICATED SACRED TO HINDUS
WILL DAIS AND JAMES. THE PLEASE
OPPOSE THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
PHONE OPERATOR IF WE CAN RECLAIM
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER- WHO I HAD
INDICATED AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
WAS NOT ON THE AGENDA IT IS IT
WAS BUT IT WAS ON AS A SUSPENSE.
AND IT'D IT WAS NOT HER TODAY
BUT THE PUBLIC COMMENT NOW IS
FOR ALSO THOSE TYPE OF BILLS
REALLY. COMMENTED ON AS WELL SO
. SHE STILL AVAILABLE. I
APOLOGIZE I DO NOT RECALL WHAT
LINE NUMBER THAT WAS. OKAY. WE
WILL BABY COULD CUT HER ONCE
AGAIN. ONE MORE WORK TRY LINE
THIRTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. AND
THIRTY SIX HAS TAKEN THEMSELVES
OUT OF QUEUE LINE TWENTY THREE.
HI MY NAME IS JUDY STORY OUR
VOLUNTEER FOUR THREE FIVE ALL
BAY AREA ACTION ON BEHALF OF THE
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND SUPPORTERS WE
SUPPORT AB. TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
LINE SIXTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME
IS ON THE MARKET THAT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN- AND ALL
OF US OR NONE- CALLING FOR A
COUPLE OF A CO SPONSORED THEM AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY. OUR CHILDREN
OF INCARCERATED PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS TASK FORCE WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND COSPONSORED
A- LOT SO- CO SPONSORS. NEXT
COMP THE PORTERS OF AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY- WE ARE NOT CO SPONSORS
BUT WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY EIGHT. A. B.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE. EIGHTEEN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE. AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE. THANK
LINE. SIXTY NINE. FIVE SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO TALKING AGAIN I'M
OPPOSING AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
TWO OF STATE CRIME WHICH HAS A
SECOND THIS AYE OPPOSED TO THE
CONFLICT CARD IS OF ONE OF THE
SACRED HINDU SYMBOL WHICH IS
ALSO SECRETIVE OF CHEN ONE LAST
FROM THE CUT AND ANYTHING OF
HATE CRIMES THAT SPANNED SENATE
THEM. WELL I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
OPEN THE BILL IN OF. HOW CAN
WHICH IS THE WHOLE CROSS INSTEAD
. MY THIS IS JUST TO HEAR YOUR
NAME. THE BILL NUMBER AND I. OF
MY ORGANS THAT YOU'RE YES MY
NAME. YEAH MY NAME IS THE THAT
THE LOVE THAT YOU MOSTLY AND I
FROM THE NEEDS OF IN ORANGE.
THANK YOU FOR A PHONE OPERATOR-WE'RE GONNA POP FOR JUST A
MOMENT ON PUBLIC WE'RE TO OPEN.
UP THE RULE ON CONSENT AND GIVE
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON TO CONSENT
. CONSENT CALENDAR BRIAN. BRIAN
I. CORREA. THANK YOU WERE GOING
TO MOVE RESUME THE PUBLIC
COMMENT- FOR TESTIMONY ON ALL
BILLS THAT WERE BEFORE US TODAY
INCLUDING THE SUSPEND CALENDAR.
THANK YOU LINE SIXTY SEVEN.
HELLO MEGGAN BOYD FROM THE TECH
CORPORATION WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR A BI Q.
ONE ZERO SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE.
SEVENTY FOUR. YES MY NAME IS
CASH CHECKS OUT HOW I'M A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND A MEMBER OF THE COALITION
OFFENDERS OF NORTH AMERICA I
OPPOSE- CALIFORNIA AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO THAT SEEKS TO
CRIMINALIZE THE SWASTIKA- AS A
HATE SYMBOL THAT SACRED TO
HINDUS BUT AS SOON JAMES AND
IT'S BEEN MISATTRIBUTED- FAR
ASSEMBLED THE SACRED. TO US
GOING BACK SIX THOUSAND YEARS
THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY YES
THANK YOU SKIP DOMON BEHALF OF
THOUSANDS OF LICENSED
SUBCONTRACTORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF MR QUIRKS BILL AB. SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN. NINE SEVENTY NINE.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRANDON VOLOKH
CALLING ON BEHALF OF DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SUMMER STEPHAN FROM THE
FINAL COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE. THANK
YOU. LINE. SEVENTY EIGHT. YEAH
HELLO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU- THIS IS
MIKE ROSENCRANTZ OF SOCAL
ADAPTIVE SPORTS AND I'M SPEAKING
IN FAVOR OF IT EIGHTY TWO THREE
SEVEN THREE- IN ORDER TO LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. EIGHTY THREE.
NINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI YES NEARLY. IN ORDER TO
PUT ALL OF US IN IDENTICAL
SERVICES WITH PRISONERS ARE
CHILDREN I'M HERE TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY COOPER
AB TWENTY THREE NINE WHERE- HERE
TO SUPPORT IT S. B. TEN AWAIT.
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE BY
BRADFORD SB EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE
BY SKINNER SB CAN I'M SORRY NO
SIR RIGHT BRANDS ARE SENATE
BILLS THAT WE'RE NOT TAKING UP.
WE'RE ONLY TAKING UP ASSEMBLY
BILLS. WHAT SAID BILLS ARE NOT
AND BEFORE'S. LINE EIGHTY FIVE.
HELLO HELLO MY NAME IS BRIDGET
JOBS SO I'M DECIDING IN ELDORADO
HIS I'M ABANDONED AS IT. AND I
OPPOSE CALIFORNIA AB TWO BLUE A
BILL CRIMINALIZING THE SWASTIKA.
I WOULD SAY THAT A DATA THAT HAS
THEIR GOOD HINDU I AM BUT I'M
AND IT SHOULD NOT BE. CONFUSED
OR MISUNDERSTOOD AT HAGEN
GROOVES. IN IT WILL BE ADDED ON
RIGHT AS I SAY THAT I CAN NOT
GOLDEN GATE VENDOR TRYING WITH
THE GIRLS SO IT HAS NOTED TEN
VIOLATIONS BECOME SO THICK I'M
TAKEN GROUP. SO I WOULD OPPOSE
THIS BILL. CRIMINAL TO STICK UP
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND FOR
THOSE WHO ARE STILL YET TO SHARE
THEIR PUBLIC COMMENT ITS NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL THAT YOU'RE CALLING ON.
THAT'S ALL WE NEED TO HEAR AT
THIS. ONCE AGAIN TO SPEAK ON ANY
BILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN. WELL. THE NEW YEAH MY
NAME IS DANIEL COMPLETE THE
COMPLETE INVOLVEMENT I'M HERE TO
AWFUL- IN AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
COOL. AB DE FICAR IF THE PEOPLE
WITH THE SAME AND AS A HATE
SYMBOL PLEASE DON'T BELIEVE THEY
DID EVENT BY BECAUSE ANYTHING
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
FOUR. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STEVE CATHOLICA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA UROLOGY SOCIETY AND
SUPPORTER AB EIGHTEEN TEN WHICH
IS ON THE SUSPECT'S CALENDAR.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES INTO IT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- WELL WE APPRECIATE THAT
PHONE OPERATOR THAT CONCLUDES
THE HEARING FOR TODAY.
WE WILL- KEEP THE MEETING OPENED
FOR ABOUT FIVE MINUTES TO ALLOW
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO TO
COME IN AND ADD ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AT WHICH TIME
. WE WILL ADJOURN THE MEETING.
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.